stated that chocolate is okay for me are you worried at all about the five grams of sugar that has
contained in a survey of 70 percent dark chocolate um you know your you can count the grams of sugar
a day you know when i was in the middle of my cancer i i would keep track of my grams of sugar
that i consumed every day and i can't remember what i kept it under what my goal was there's just
something i like that left brain kind of data to kind of keep track of things like that
but you know i have a strong sweet tooth that's a that's a big downfall for me and i've shared
that multiple times the zoom calls and but chocolate was kind of a break for me because five grams
for uh for a stack once a day was pretty darn low so um if if if you have that sweet tooth that
you really want to fill something then um it you know chocolate that dark chocolate can be a nice
thing to make your life a little bit better so um at that sense i'd say no i'm not concerned about that